they're keeping sanctions in reserve
they're not going to hit him with a 10.
they want to start maybe with a two
see how things go
boost it up to a three if he goes into
bel if he goes into poland you know they
want to be able to keep that flexibility
do you think that's a good idea would
you have hit the russians harder out of
the gate
well if the scenario is what you just
described we're saving a few bullets if
the next step is into a nato country i
would hope the response would be a
little more than sanctions at that point
there is a bright line it is the nato
line and as we listened to jen griffin
earlier it appears shockingly in that
answer to your question jesse he's
putting troops on the border of poland
and so once we get to the baltic states
once we get to poland once we get to
romania we're treaty bound at this point
to respond more heavily than with
sanctions so what are we saving some
sanctions for what are those few bullets
you describe jesse for i don't know
because i don't know what more putin can
do in ukraine that wouldn't warrant our
full economic response i would imagine
we should we should usher in i mean he
could do a number of things he could cut
off the pipeline that goes through
ukraine he could execute the president i
think they are trying to save some
things in reserve they keep asking about
swift
but i don't think the president wants to
do swift why and explain to the audience
what swift is because we keep hearing
swift swift
what does that mean i got to go back in
time a little bit to when i was white
house press secretary when i first
learned what swift was i had no idea but
it was uh actually i think it was about
putin at the time too talking about when
he tried to invade georgia and then got
pushed back out of there so swift is
where financial transactions go through
and it makes things quite uh smooth in
the world financial system right but you
can track it and you can stop it and so
that's one of the ways that you talk
about stopping terrorist financing that
was would be one way everyone needs to
use swift now here's the thing biden
can't unilaterally do that the europeans
have to go the europeans are a part of
this it is housed in belgium and as i
understand it italy and germany were
quite reluctant they didn't want to go
that far so if you don't want to go that
far you're just allowing putin to go
his next far and
my husband i'm going to give him credit
peter just sent me a note listening to
duleep in the briefing he said
so russians are now going to have to pay
15 interest rates to borrow bunny but
why are they allowed to borrow money at
all and i think it's a good point
because i don't understand why you
couldn't have done some of these
sanctions would seem fairly timid
although two days are better
before because as kamla hara said you
know it's supposed to deter and then
biden has to say today well nobody
thought it was going to deter anything
so what have we been doing for the past
three months exactly so so this is
swift lets you take your atm card and
use it in italy or belgium
so i get that so it's an internet okay i
was gonna i was gonna ask you what
happens if putin surrounds the capitol
he occupies the country's total control
and then he waits a couple weeks maybe a
month and he gauges the pain threshold
of the sanctions and he says you know
what
don't really feel it that much things
are all right we got plenty of money we
loaded for bear we're going to move now
that's going to look like a huge
strategic miscalculation on the byte
administration's part that they didn't
go in harder and and pierce uh putin
personally right away well i uh i agree
with your
implied harder line i think that we
could have had a harder line uh we you
talk about uh
warped narratives
the the most warped narrative is that
putin has sold the russian people that
he's de-nazifying ukraine he's
denotifying ukraine he's denotifying the
only country that has a jewish leader
outside of israel he's dean not he's
such a he's a punk he's an absolute punk
craig and i were in uh afghanistan
pakistan tribal territories 1980.
the big old russian army are rolling
into afghanistan they're going to kick
ass they're going to take over they're
going to rule all of south asia guess
what 1980
the
economy collapses the soviet union
collapses on the back of the of the the
mujahideen armed with their little
stinger missiles and their
rpgs and so forth this is going to be
mujahideen squared as long as they don't
get zielinski the russian
the the ukraine president is such a
valuable
symbol right now we have to do whatever
we can whether it's surreptitious or
whatever it is with private security
whatever it is we have to keep zelinski
alive and in country as long as he's in
country putin has not won putin cannot
win if the ukraine president is alive
and well and fighting it that's
possible i disagree with that because
putin has already said
that he is going to take
the uh leaders who resist him and put
them on trial now i don't believe that
putin believes in a trial putin believes
in poisoning people in front of the
world
and he has no concerns about it and let
me just say something about sanctions
because we've been talking about
sanctions for the last hour same the
next crimea putin did in 2014. did the
sanctions work no
and then what we had were biden waived
the sanctions and allowed russia on the
pipeline on north stream too so he's
waived them so far so there is so much
that we've done that has given putin the
belief that he can get away with it and
in addition to that we have no sanction
against
putin personally it's like we're not
going to touch him we're waiting for
that
yeah waiting right and the international
banking system how's he gonna sell oil
if he can't get the money from the
international banking system okay
there's got to be a way to convince
italy and and and germany because people
are dying as we speak and let's stop
talking about time because he is in a
position to take keeve in the next 24 to
48 hours according to the military
experts so this long term let's see the
sanctions
and putin does not care about his people
he doesn't care about what whether they
like him or love him or hate him that's
for sure hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else